get in there sir i don't smell anything
yet well you're not close enough
[Music]
i read something really sexy about you
you were a bed wetter uh
how old was she when she last wet the
bed oh you like this well i was
oh oh
i was um i just went did you just go all
over my couch a little bit
you were like 15. you were 15 when you
stopped wetting the bed yeah wow
then that year that no the month after i
got fired from saturday night live i
went to bed three times really really
are you serious did you have a boyfriend
do you ever wet the bed with a boyfriend
in the bed yeah you did
with a friend yeah that i was staying
with in la and like a guy yeah but i'd
like sleep in his bed if he didn't have
a girl over whatever yeah a lot of
chicks do that by the way you wouldn't
have sex with him you just sleep in his
bed all right so so the first time you
wet the bed
uh was with this guy he was your friend
and then when you were there yeah and
were you embarrassed i mean you must
have been like oh my god it was one of
those things
the second i woke up i knew i had to say
it right away or it would be too
embarrassing i was like dave i peed in
your bed and he was like i'm so gonna
just put a towel down oh really yeah so
i never had that problem like do you
just dream that you're paying or yeah in
the bathroom yeah what happens i don't
know i don't know i just woke up and i
was i was really warm in one spot and i
moved then i was really cold
you just don't even know what's
happening i mean i wake up out of a dead
sleep and go to sleep
yeah like two times a night sometimes
because i drink so much freaking water
and it it's so annoying maybe it'd be
easier if i could just put a bucket
under me and pee in the damn bed but i'm
so damn anal i won't pee in the bed like
like you wake up after you pee to bed
right
no i wake up and then i pee in the bed
no you wake up i'm saying does it wake
you up after like the fact that you're
you peed in the bed i think so it does i
don't know i'm not i can't tell how old
the p is
like can't you have somebody figure out
wow
this is three hours old all right so
then you so the next time you peed the
bed after saturday night live was when
you were with a guy sexually when you
were in a romantic relationship that's
got to be weird it was all like in the
same month did the guy understand
yeah he didn't guys will understand i
could not nobody cared i mean they're
all like
oh
so then what do they do you get up and
you change the sheets and stuff
yeah yeah i don't wet the bed anymore it
was just kind of like it was kind of it
was kind of adorable howard
when you read uh steve martin's book and
who is naturally fine i mean right but
when you read that book you see how hard
he worked at it that's what you're
talking about and it's he is as easily
as funny right now as he ever was yeah
i mean naturally funny when i talk to
him i go that's so funny why doesn't he
just you know they'd write that down or
something i can tell you i had
like i witnessed
steve martin in the moment brilliance
moment
i was
this is very named robbie but i because
we did um you know one of those afi
honors we did it for steve martin i did
that and then also for diane keaton so
afterwards we all went to steve's house
just a few people very intimate i mean i
was like dying you know like
um it's a special moment you go i've
arrived oh and candace bergen was there
and and diane keaton who is like
a fabulous actress god amazing nancy
myers and and then of course martin
short and seymour anyway
martin short kind of becomes like the
host and asks questions to get
conversation started and he said candace
when did you first meet steve
and candice goes
uh i remember i was hanging out with
lorne
and paul
and
steve didn't know what prosciutto was
and then steve right then goes can you
believe it and now i drive one
i may need to go embed it in my head so
i never forget
let me just recap this ball smelling
thing richard was here on monday and you
said i want to smell your balls and he
said to you this is such a silly day to
do it because they showered sunday night
unfortunately i showered last night i'm
here till wednesday wednesday they'll
come in wednesday and smell themselves
before the view
yeah that'll be funky by wednesday would
you do that for me i would love to see
you smell his balls uh sure richard tell
sarah what has happened since sun since
monday when she was here so she knows
what she's smelling so three or four
shits i masturbated three times
without like cleaning up like when i i
lay in bed sometimes i'll masturbate and
then just pull my underwear up after i'm
done all right so get get in the chair
get naked and smell your balls she gets
it
[Music]
sarah christ
now your legs are spread richard you're
very provocative
all right hold them up
you're a brave woman you're really brave
i think this is the funniest thing i've
ever heard of get in there i don't smell
anything yet well you're not close
enough
gabby's got a gas room
[Music]
oh
you were about six or seven inches away
from his balls
oh she can't stop gagging you really
smelled it bad huh
oh my god how bad is it it was a hint of
raw sourdough dough in a vat of
mayonnaise
that was in a trunk
of like a 70s car
for the summer for the summer right the
hottest summer of the year
i was thinking about your acting career
you kind of uh blew off a big
opportunity
this was the time when mad men i'm just
saying i have terrible instincts
like when mad men happened i was friends
with jon hamm he played a cable guy on
the sarah silverman program yeah right
so then he called me and he's like hey
i'm doing this pilot on amc you should
audition for it and i said
uh uh i'm not gonna audition for a pilot
on amc like i was laughing
that's that old movie channel but you
were even even more outraged you said to
him listen i've got my own tv show
yeah go [ __ ] off and then oh i remember
getting the script um i mean these
aren't offers or anything but like my
agent sent me the script for um
bridesmaids and i just read the title
and was like [ __ ] this
and now that's probably my i've seen
that like 15 times does this
time favorite movies do you are you
filled with regret when something like
that happens when you no you don't you
don't dwell on i don't watch bridesmaids
and go oh i should have played this part
of this part i just watch it and i love
it like i die laughing every time
and i remember when i first came out
like when i first was working the pilot
for friends was floating around the uh
script i heard you were sort of offered
something in france 100 no no i was i
was too young i was younger but um i
remember the script going around and
crying laughing at how dumb the title
was
sometimes when you're a very smart
comedian that you that you're almost too
hip for the room and every everything is
kind of silly and stupid like friends is
stupid oh i'm not bridesmaid oh i'm not
going to go on amc like it's almost like
you're too smart for your own building
my favorite thing
right
when you were on in 2018
you were talking about the kind of porn
that you like oh
my god this is the greatest i found a
new one that really is like a victimless
crime
where it's like guys either jerking
they're um [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] um
pocket
[ __ ] or like these real dolls that
look really real but they're teeny tiny
you watch that i it's so great because
they're like yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] love but it's a rubber dog
but like there's no woman really there
and so it's amazing it's like everything
i want and nobody gets hurt after
leaving there i you know i didn't think
anything of it and maybe a cup you know
it's not like i'm looking at porn
constantly but usually like
there's about a week every month just
hormonally where i become an animal and
i must
look at you know look at porn several
times over a couple days and then um a
new video popped up because i you know
there's only like eight of them it's
very
specific
and i uh i start watching it
and
i'm you know like on lying on my stomach
and looking at my phone and i have to
turn my my glasses are progressive so i
have to like turn them upside down it's
really i have put tape over the hole
because even a hacker doesn't deserve to
have to see that but i find this one and
i watch it i fast forward a little bit
to the so he's about to come part and
it's got all the elements i want it's
the it's dark the guy's from the neck
down he's on the side of his shitty bed
at the pocket [ __ ] wedged in there's
like a pile of laundry in the foreground
it's just like makes it real
yeah
and as he's coming he says
sarah silverman he says my whole name
twice
now
my first reaction is i had a heart
attack i thought someone was like
hacking like looking through
at me
i rewinded a little and i watch it again
no in this video he's going oh oh sarah
silverman sarah silverman then he starts
laughing a little and he goes that's
what you like right and i i can't
believe it i just happened upon it
somebody
made a porn for me like
i've never been so honored and i
couldn't believe it and i am i mean
crazy howard i got a star on the
hollywood walk of fame and
this is
this is more of an honor i think you
know by the way i have a clip of it and
imagine sarah's laying there in her
belly she's taped her eyeglasses upside
down on her nose so she can see what's
going on they don't have to tape them
and then all of a sudden this comes
doesn't happen [ __ ] yeah oh i'm a sarah
silverman oh yeah yeah sarah silverman
you like that don't you
why is he laughing sarah
i don't know because he did this crazy
thing so his at so i look at what his
his code name is on pornhub or whatever
and it's grip van winkle
and i think
i go i gotta contact this guy's i mean i
don't want him to have my you know
information but if there's any way i can
like contact him just so he knows like i
saw it
so i click on it and here's the very odd
addendum his avatar
on his page of on pornhub is like the
money grubbing propaganda jew from from
the holocaust you know like oh no and
i'm like oh my god like
this guy hates jews and then it kind of
makes sense because i in the world of
like fantasy
i'm sure there are jews that have like
nazi fantasies and there must be like
nazis that have jew fantasies did you
get in touch with him i never found him
no this is a call to action find grib
van winkle but do you want to find grip
van winkle if he doesn't like uh jews
yes you do want to find him you want to
talk to him
i have a million questions
you supported president obama and you
were in a private meeting with him how
[ __ ] weird is that wait where did you
read that i know here's the thing i did
have a meeting with i got to meet him
for like three minutes now hold it when
you say you got to meet him you went to
a private room and met him right like
in a hotel i was waiting in a
like almost like a hallway that he was
walking through and would like meet me
on the way to another thing it wasn't
like
immediate you know it was like it it was
arranged it wasn't a big it was it was
arranged because you supported him and
did a video for him during the campaign
was that the maybe maybe but you know i
think the white house doesn't want
people
to be able to use fodder like oh he's
meeting with celebrities meanwhile i'm
not a celebrity i made a video for it
you know what i mean i don't think it's
so bad that he gave me two minutes of
his time while he was just saying thank
you so what was the meeting anyway i
mean okay i mean it wasn't me but it was
really like it was just me
uh my agent michael kivas who does a lot
of work at the white house he's like a
political guy or he's the guy who sends
them movies and stuff when they want
movies
and uh he walks through
and just know that i know i mean it's
very nice what he said but i know that
there was somebody right before he
walked through he's like she's a
comedian she's from around the world she
made a video you know i mean it's not
like i think yeah
yeah shakes my annie goes oh
i'm a big fan you're very you're very
talented though i turned the volume down
when my girls come into the room i was
like oh hahaha thank you
and then um
but i was so nervous and excited like
it's so funny because before i went in
there i was like what should i bring up
i emailed my like uh brother-in-law
who's like in israel and a real
political guy he's like ask him about
darfur and this and number one i'm like
yeah yeah but then of course you get
there and you're just like hi
[Laughter]
he goes uh
kevis is talking about them you know how
he likes foreign films and it's very
impressive he goes yeah i don't like the
bloody stuff i don't like the scary
stuff and i go and all of a sudden i
feel my mouth moving and i'm like me
either i don't even like pixar movies
that they i the thought of a lonely
robot in space kills me you know
and then he's like well i'll have to
disagree with you on the pixar front and
i'm like huh and then he goes what do
you have coming up and then i go i'm
going to be naked in a movie
i had no control over my mouth i don't
know
jimmy you used to be my world
[Applause]
howard you have given us all so much and
uh
i feel like we your fans are like these
these bottomless pits you know because
as much as you give and as much as you
give to us
we will always want more
and when i think of all the memories i
have
you know as a guest and as a listener
more than anything
i just i wish that we could freeze time
so that this show would just never ever
ever end
thank you
it's been said time march is on and
we've gotta take stock
but i don't wanna howard i don't wanna
this show is my rock
your contract's up in two more years and
if you don't renew well die of shock
[Music]
stop the clock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
meat and veg for her masturbation
she tripped on drugs so she could find
life's answer but instead she got a
super gross
grapefruit-sized cancer
[Music]
eating right
gives you cancer
howard doesn't want to breathe your
germs he never dyed his hair he never
[Music]
tiny penis only comes one spur
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] in every stall
rabbit's got big round [ __ ] walls i get
on fumes from richard christie's balls
she
gets from mr christie's balls
[Music]
with me
[Music]
you're my rock
[Music]
stop the clock
[Music]
[Applause]